bonjour à toutes et à tous bienvenue
pour cette petite vidéo en compagnie de
Sophie bonjour Sophie va souffrir
aujourd'hui parce que j'ai j'ai
redécouvert le documentaire de mon
enfance la la VHS qui a bercé mon
enfance le son de la VHS je l'imagine
déjà 1993 1993 la vidéo officielle du
Muséum d'histoire naturelle de
Londres euh sur les dinosaures que
j'avais quand j'étais petit j'étais tout
petit déjà 1993 alors non je l'avais en
français mais mais bon là on n pas
découvert en français donc ça va être
anglais sous-titré YouTube
youtube Regardez ça dinosaur trop bien
c'est trop bien donc du coup c'est une
vidéo bon ça fait une petite cquaine de
minutes et donc Sophie elle va elle va
elle va je vais découvrir elle va
découvrir et moi je vais revivre alors
je ça peut pas être un desbunkage et
pénitence pour moi je je j'ai un soft
spot quoi avoir des les il y aura il y
aura zéro objectivité sur cette vidéo
tout est g Richard Owen Richard Owen
mesdames et messieurs à l'époque la
seule vraie position de Richard Owen
c'était dans le hall c'était dans le
hall d'entrée exactement
oui remplacé par Charles Darwin
voilà Charles Darwin là sa mre non mais
rien plus tout se perd t se perd tout se
perd alors que Richard il était à sa
place voilà à l'entrée de directement le
premier ch le premier truc qui vous
accueille le regard glaçant de l'homme
que disje l'homme la
bête cette cette vidéo elle est
présentée par Richard Owen c'est un
documentaire mesdames et messieurs
présenté par Richard Owen et ça ça
mesdames et messieurs c'est grandiose et
c'est en 3D c'est en 3D donc en fait on
avait c'était vendu avec des des
lunettes en fait et il fallait mettre
des lunettes et donc ce genre de
séquence comme vous voyez là j'ai des
relant Nintendo 64 rien à faire ah non
là c'est super nest là c'est star wing
sur super c'est du bon gros polygone là
starfx là qui
fait non ça cétaitit c'était avant
c'était avant do r vous avez pas connu
vous non c'était dans celui-là qui
disait do r si tuéta dans celui-là non
ouais c'est dans celui-là qui dit et la
musique la musique voilà ép alors le le
budget musique il était comme ça comme
ça et le budget fait spaau était comme
ça tu disais mê eff spé que Jurassic par
ça oui la jaquette la jaquette de donc
c'est c'est un temps que le moins de 20
ans ne peuvent pas connaître où on
acheté une cassette vidéo à l'époque une
VHS à sa couverture et donc dans sa sur
la couverture de ce documentaire
Mesdames et Messieurs les m il y avait
écrit les effets spéciaux ont été fait
avec les mêmes ordinateurs que Jurassic
Park c'est planté attention il s'est
planté il a glissé chef Gliss glissé
ptivier ptivier qu'est-ce que tu as fait
Nonin comme ça comme
ça donc il a pas l'air contenti la VHS
disait les effets spéciaux ont été faits
par avec les mêmes ordinateurs que pour
Jurassic Park ce qui n'est pas un
mensonge parce qu'effectivement à
l'époque les les effets spéciaux de
Jurassic Park ont été fait par des jeux
sur des ordinateurs de bureau classiques
en tout cas c'est ce que dit c'est ce
que dit le making of de Jurassic par et
du coup effectivement ça a été fait avec
les mêmes ordinateurs mais pas pas avec
les mêmes personnes wi
contre et là c'est le cauchemar parce
que tu es enfermé dans le noir tout seul
avec
Richard es tout seul dans le noir dans
le muséum d'Histoire
Natur
avecard pourquoi il dit qu'il sera là
demain
puisque il s'est endormi pendant que la
meuf elle faisait son speech tu sais je
suis censé être la de mal le mec il est
tellement à
l'ouest rien à faire ça les Pierr à feu
ça c'est de la référence alors Richard
Owen en plus dans ce documentaire il est
très gentil il est représenté avec une
certaine bonomie comme vous voyez qui
n'était absolument pas caractéristique
du personnage il a une bonne tête dans
le
documentaire là là c'était un des
passages préférés que sur la cassette
c'est quand il explique l'histoire de la
Terre sur le squelette de dipl c'est di
le diplodocus les les moins de 5 ans ne
peuvent pas connaître dip diplodocus
parce qu'elle a quitté le Muséum il y a
5 ans je crois que c'était y a 5 ans
plus c'est diplodocus qui était autrefis
à l'entrée du Muséum d'Histoire
Naturelle autre l'entrée du
musé une baleine ce qui est pas si mal
en soi mais disons que la plupart des
musées ont des baleines alors que la
plart des musées n'ont pas un de en plus
c'est il
estelui de donc c'est un spécimen
historique donc là il lui explique que
si l'histoire de la Terre c'est tout le
diplodocus alors l'être humain c'est le
dernier ose de la queue et c'est quand
même cool bien
cool c'est mieux que partir sur une une
montre pour expliquer le truc parce que
bon sur le sur l'URE c'est sympa mais je
trouve ça toujours un peu abstrait au
final pour les petits enfants c'est pas
facile souvent on utilise un calendrier
mais c'est vrai que avec le squelette en
fait ça permet de montrer en perspective
où où sont les dinosaures donc les
dinosaures sont au milieu de la que
c'est c'est téléporté donc l'être humain
c'est le dernier rose tout au bout de la
queue c'est trop bien
W il Richard Owen c'est un Jedi
et Jedi ça se téléporte pas et
caca non c'est un super sa les Jedi ça
se téléporte pas quand tu fermes les
yeux et que tu mets les truc là c'est un
super Saian attention c'est
ça ah oui et donc ça c'est les moments
en 3D donc il fallait mettre des
lunettes qui étaient vendues avec la
cassette il y en avait deux paires
et la magie de la
3D 1993 Mesdames et Messieurs cétaétait
le début c'était le tout début
Terminator c'était que 2 ans avant
Terminator 2 c'était que 2 an pas les mê
spé non
plus voilà c'est le la musique est très
bien la musique a John Williams au on a
mis John Williams à la musique et on a
mis Casimir aux effets
spéciaux
le bronosur alors l'eau est
intéressant la simulation de l'eau c'est
c'est regard encore JDG hier qui se
plaignait de la qualité de la simulation
de l'eau dans pubg
oua comparé à ça ça
va alors les arbres il sont très beau
aussi là il explique que les dinosaures
ils ont les jambes droites sous le corp
effectivement Richard qui l'a découver
en plus c'est intéressant y a du jus
derrière du jus ah ça c'est pas un
dinosaure parce qu'il a les il a les
pattes sur le côté et puis lui il est
pas en image de synthèse non plus vous
le voyez
bien écoutez la musique la
[Musique]
musiqueillette mus ils ont le trè œil
sur le haut du crâne aussi c'est marant
ah oui c'est un IG il a un piné c'est ça
et donc si vous le grattez sur l'œil
petit truc d'ailleurs si vous avait un
ils aiment beaucoup être gratté sur
l'œil parce que ça démange régulièrement
ils peuvent pas se gratter à cet endroit
donc si vous les Gratz là ils aiment
bien c'est
un et il y a les pieds qui collent et ce
sont pas des dinosaures parce que ces
pieds ils dépassent sur le
côté ah la musique est bien quand est-ce
que tu as vu une musique aussi sympa
dans un film ou un documentaire j'ai pas
vu de
musique je suis sûr qu'on peut voir la
partition mais en tous les cas en tous
les cas mais c'est quoi
ça c'est transport
Rex la traductionéress traduction
connais pas le mot Tyrannosaurus
visiement ah c'est un Alosa c'est un
allosa ah c'est pour ça je disais
qu'est-ce qu'il a audessus de la tête
non c'est effectivement d'accord ok
modèle il a
chié effectivement les petites pointes
et les tris
[Applaudissements]
doigts là c'est le
tripcide avec la musique c'est un
dinosaure volant non ça c'est un
jouet je va même pas m'arrêter sur le
fait que lesosaures sont pas des
dinosaures ça c'est
vraiment ils ont les ongles
violetsé je sais pas c'est du
VHS j'aime beaucoup la me
les c'est ce qui arriv en fait quand
turêis la cette que la bande se coinca
dans le dans le magnétoscope
oui puis vous voyez les petit les petits
arf c'est de la vraie va
cherie là il explique il explique la
division en TR
périodes 228 milli le Trias à 228
millions d'années vous avez pas connu ça
les
jeunes on faisait commencer le tri à 228
millions d'années C
ah ou ou ça c'est bon maintenant il
commence à 252 millions
d'années encore une
foourour des modles comme ça on vair le
tour pas
grandose on voit pas grand chose c'est
un peu truc quandme et donc ça on était
censé le voir en 3D avec les
lunettes 3 a juste mon
écran 65 milli
d'Ann c'est 66 millions d'années c'est
arrivé dans les années 2000 à l'époque
c'était
65 SAF si vous regardez si vous regardez
le film de 2022 qui s'appelle
65 asu il est tellement parle de
tricérat sans le regarder comme
ça il class une classe il con il conna
sa
BES
caca au début
CR donc là ce qu'on ce qui nous montre
en fait c'est le l'exposition qu'il y
avait à l'époque sur les dinosaures au
Muséum d'histoire naturelle de lomes H
et qui a pas tant changé que ça parce
que j'y suis quand on y était allé je
sais pas si tu te rappelles mais c'est à
peu près les mêmes c'est à peu près les
mêmes fossiles qui sont toujours exposé
encore aujourd'hui bah c'est les plus
jolis je pense
alors là il nous montre barionix la
raison pour laquelle on pense que
spinosaure est pivor c'est parce que on
a découvert en Angleterre barionix qui
avait des du poisson dans son contenu
stomacal des écailles de
finalement c'est quandme c'estme bien
c'est un documentaire à mon avis
évidemment ça fait 20 ans que je l'ai
Pasu mais à mon avis pas VI pourant que
je me
rappelle ça fait un peu mal aux
yeux
explique le principe de la
transformation il sont
téléport je sais pas comment ils sont
passés en fait de C moulage de
tricératops voilà comment la filisation
fonctionne ce il est en train de faire
les poussières je
suppose Richard Owen il a jamais foutu
les pieds les mains dans le Cambou que
les choses so clair recevit les trucs il
recevait les trucs et c'est il les
décrivait quand on voit les spécimens de
l'époque d'ailleurs ils étaient à peine
préparés en plus qu'on savait pas
exactement comment le faire non
plus regardez ce beau Bionix
h
p faire des
moulag
les les copies des dinosaures
éch
comprendo
[Musique]
VI
d'AM
après on découvrira le reste du en le
reste du squelette sera publié
deus mais donc à l'époque il savait pas
trop à quoi ça
ressemblaitus que les pant il y avait
que les PES avant alors il d que ça
devit ressem àos parce que les
BR mais du coup on a découvert qu'il
avait ressembl une
spatule
pe le bec plat et une petite bosse sur
le dos et il était effectivement
gigantesque ça ressem Maus Afrique du
Sud
représente TR du coup à l'époque
deard
Angleterre sinon ce sera non ça do tre
une
copie ça va tuas 15 ans pas trop content
de toi non
plus je
sais
ah c'est vrai est à de niveau en fait tu
fais d'abord la passerelle en métal et
ensite tu descends pas des g
d'animatronique aussi sur la fin je
croura pas
mais aura pas mais là quand on l'
animatroni il y a des animatroni dans
documentaire j
j sont les
anens
ça là ils expliquent la différence
entreosaurus et
Tyrannosaurus toujours
important parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
bah c'est comme le gamin il fait à
chaque fois c'est ça trerex non c'est
çax toujours c'est ça TX mais
c'est un stgosur
ça sur le
[Rires]
dos VO là là là là il y a de l'anglais
là
très
briti le modèle sportif def que les mod
SP généralement ça sort après les
premiers
modèlesers ah il est
féroce le temps est-ce que c'esti plus F
méchant lequel le plus méchant c'est
lequel le plus féroce c'est lequel le
plus
redoutable c'est c'est une
représentation assez fidèle de ce qui se
passe dans un musée et que tuas 15
gamins qui ça c'est le
tuangurus je m' rappelle parce que la
cassette tuangosaurus
C c'était mon pr quand j'étais petit
je trouvais
sympa le langage chinois tout le me
conna vous parlez pas mandarin
courams dé ch et tu parles pas
l'Africain
[Rires]
plus le
MIM le
MIM il cour pas là mais bon imagin une
autuch je pense que tuurais pas
aimé cette blague n'est plus drôle
depuisette
[Musique]
BL
gr
[Musique]
pour tradite comme ça je me rappelle
pas VI dans un environnement
exclusivement composé de cascade comme
tu peux le constater
c'est joli c'est très joli une fois de
plus j'attire votre attention sur la
musique la musique elle est quand même
bien
[Musique]
foutue ah mais c'est joli bah oui c'est
très joli tu t'imagines en 3D là c'est
tu es en 93 c'est le r j'étais gamin les
lunettes 3D de 93 céta pas to non plus
non mais c'était l'époque tu te rappelle
pas il y avait les les magazines là il y
avait les
magazines tu avais genre la double page
du milieu qui était en 3D et tu étais là
oh mon dieu c'est trop beau alors que
c'était Vert et Rouge dégueulasse et tu
avais aussi ça dans les boîes de
céréales il t'ofrait la paire de
lunettes tu dans les boes de céréales
des fois c'était c'était le rêve à
l'époque c'était c'était le futur j'ai
toujours trouvé ça très c'était trop le
futur et puis le
BR dans le noet aussi tu l'as eu le
squelette qui Brill dans le no qui et
après si tu continu à acheter don la
peau à monter sur le squelette et ça
n'avait aucun intérêt du coup tu avais
plus
Lequette Pasel j'avais d'autes truc qui
BR dans pas de
[Musique]
dinosaant é
déjà une cassette qui est stie c'est un
peu basé
sur voilà
exactement donc effectivement c'est
comme ça qu'aur réagi les enfants de
l'époque en voyant denonicus en là il
appelle ça des dromosaurus je pense que
c'est je sais pas si c'est des
dromosaurus ou desic le crâne ressemble
pas
àonus mais je crois pas qu'on a des
squelettes complè
dromos j'avoue que me balader la nuit
dans le Muséum histoire naturelle à lond
ou à Paris d'ailleurs ça peut être une
expérience
gamin quand même oui ou oui bah ça c'est
c'est à ça que ressemble l'exposition en
plein jour c'est
complètement ah pourquoi il y a autant
de dinosaures au Canada et bonne
question alors parce qu'il y a plus de
gens qui cherchent
là-bas ça c'est un mensonge celui-là il
vient de bernissard il vient pas de
l' il trouvé ils en trouvé à l' je crois
pas qu'ils ont un squelette complet mais
ça ça ressemble à la préservation de
berniss oui
puisçon avec la bonne position en
kangourou à
l'ancienne on va sauter mais un pouce
d'iguanod vers
leut si c'est pas
la faire dire à Richard en qui a
nomméiguanodon un ami à moi qui
s'appelle Mantel
c'était pas ton pote Mel ah non pas du
tout non il il lui a un peu volé son
boulot je pense que tu aurais pu choper
la caramine et lui tirer dans le dos tu
l'aurais é pas po du tout Richard Owen
et manel jidéo
Mentel mon Hur ils ont fait un banquet
dans
l'iguanodon
spéci ah ou et avec la
oui parce que du coup il pensait que
c'était le bout du nez c'est ça du génie
du génie ceci dit je crois que c'est
cuvier Owen attends il y a les noms et
l'aut Mantel ah c'est
ça je sais pas pourquoi cuvier il s'est
greffé là parce qu'il était déjà mort je
crois à
l'époque on est on est en 1840 il est
déjà
mort je sais pas ce que son nom fait là
là il explique justement que le nez
c'est pas lez cétait le
pouit partout cette image là tu te
Rapp par dans les magazines la
couverture
mag comme
ça
bien
es encore parti sur ton poulet
toiam il d'
KFC mais nouriss ce qu'il a
[Musique]
for ah il explique la différence par
contre la traduction la traduction
YouTube est pourri ouais bah bah ça si
je l'avais trouvé en
français c'est c'est plus de 25 € pour
acheter le dvd he maintenant c'est de la
folie ah c'est collector oh la
vache j'aime bien j'aime bien comment
par contre parazofus il
connaît genre le truc le moins réaliste
de cette vidéo c'est qu'un gamin de 1993
sache pas dire parazorolofus mieux qu'un
adulte c'est vrai ça c'estasf en 1993
tout le monde dire parazorol tous les
gamins de qui qui sont en âge d'avoir vu
Jurassic Park savent dire parazorolopus
parfaitement tu n'apprendras pas un
enfant à dire parazurolopus en 1993 ça
c'est bah ceux qui sont intéressés par
les dinosaures du moins les autres ils
s'en fichent ah on était tous intéressés
par pas non j'en connaiss que j'en
fich mais dans quel trou tuas même moi
j'ai grandi à la campagne tout le monde
aimit les dinosaures ah oui tu es
sû le
monde où est-ce que tu as
[Musique]
grandi à l'époque il av il av pas
trad je rappelle dans cette cassette il
dis pelv et
selv pouroi je sais
pas et du coup ouais ils avaient pas
pris euh soriskien
etiskien à chaque fois les armes ils
font ils me font tripper les arbres
quand tu vois la tête des branches là en
fait il est en prison là tu le vois pas
mais non mais on dirait les épines tu
sais les épines des acacia qu'on a par
chez nous le mec qui a simulé ça n'a
jamais vu
d'arbre je sais pas ce qu'il a fait avec
ses
branches ah oui il explique gastrolite
les
n est sur
avec les deux PES comme ça tu as
l'impression qu'il est mais là il
tiendra pas non non il
ti c'est intéressant tu vois il explique
que l'herbe n'existait pas à l'époque
des dinosaures que les fruits non plus
n'existaient pas il devaent manger des
fougettes c'est bien tuenais plein de
choses en regardant
ça est-ce que le Stos dress sur ses
pattes de derrière c'était ber à
l'époque qui avait proposé ça en 1986
dans le thodactyle rose
bon voilà ça sortait pas n part du coup
non mais disons que ça ça fait un peu
bizarre de le voir en 3 comme ça sur un
modèleu en regardant cette énorme
forme en la touchant de façon
trè c'est pas vrai le
POB Richard
POB se coup ils ont changé la
transitionort de nul part on l' pas
vu un
[Musique]
Gastr connaissait les gastrolites à
l'époque de arriv un petit peu après
avecou parce qu'il a quand même fallu
trouver un un
dinosaur avec des batteries les
[Musique]
batteries ça c'est unile que je
comprenais pas quand j'étais
gamin pas s prend ouis c'est ça là en
fait l'arrière est vers la gauche du
coup
du coup je comprenais pas si c'était
l'extérieur ou l'intérieur je voyais pas
les dents en fait c'est comme une dent
d'éléphant en fait quand tu vois une d
pour la prière fois tu as un peu de mal
à savoir comment ça fonctionne c'est ça
compr pas trop pas
[Musique]
mal
pe VO non mais tu peux mettre tes
lunettes par
contre ah la musique la
musique la nostalgie la
nostalgie fermez la
musiquecouter le solo
[Musique]
oui
qu'est-ce qu'il est moche
bonsir les petits
bras
[Musique]
ça ah donc c'était l'époque c'était
l'époque où Jack Horner avait proposé
qu'il était Charon hm hm aussi donc là
ils sont en train d'en
débattre et du coup ils te disent juste
que l'hypothèse existe voilà que c'était
un char
possiblement depuis on a découvert des
des fossiles avec des dents de T-Rex
planté dedans et des tissus cicatriciels
pardessus ce qui montre que l'animal
qu'il a mordu était vivant a survéu
quand il a mordu dedans voilà ah oui
montre-nous la queue on sen
F
camé
caméra ont fait des ostéodermes pe S et
le retour à la
réalité c'est marrant les cornes il les
ont fait dans un truc qui est très
réfléchissant un matéau qui rééch bien à
lumière du coup tu as l'impression
qu'elles sont super brillantes qu'on les
austr fait pour avant veniroi on a
l'impression qu' son recouvertes de
[Musique]
plastock de la
3D après voilà je fais pas mieux sur
Blender hnêtementut faut être honnête la
sculpture 3D c'est pas évident ah non
c'est pas évident c'est c'est S
moyensépo mais ça pique un peu les yeux
mais c'est surtout quand on voit les
moyens qu'ils y ont mis par ailleurs
genre la musique la mise en scène ça on
se demande a quand même un peu faire
mieux pour
j'imagine que c'est des mouements de
caméra un peu compliqué pour pour un
ordinateur de l'époque
aussiire 3D comme ça non non la caméra
elle est juste en train de tourner
autour pas super compliqué non
plus on est passé dans les
textures c'est l'époque où il disait que
les plaques sur le dos servaient à la
termorégulation oui encore pas très loin
é tu te souviens des jeux vidéo qu'on
avait regardé l'autre fois c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'
disait
çaou donc ça c'est resté c'est les
enfants de l'époque qui ont regardé ça
et qui sont dit après ça do être vrai
c'est ce que c'est complètement ce que
j'allais dire c'est c'est maintenant les
adultes d'aujourd'hui ont appris ces
trucs là en fait et du coup
effectivement ça c'était les trucs qui
circulaient les infos qui circulaient à
l'époque et du coup maintenant c'est
c'est entré dans la culture B c'est
ça
attention il est méchant même ses
paupières comment est-ce que Richard il
connait les
temp bonne question non moi je l' POS
mais en même temps on est d'accord que
c'est une incarnation de Richard Owen
pendant qu'il est en train de dormir en
train de regarder le cours de sa prof
c'est c'est M c'est richardow gentil en
plus alors non c'est rien
ça ont une reconstitution de la corne
mais avec ENF la corne de tricératops
mais avec de la kératine
dessus leuxb protocatop
vocaptor
c'est une vidéo
tout qu'est-ce que
c'est du
caca c'est bien parce queand Mme présent
au jeunes Britan
registreoss de
[Musique]
che mais la forme la formeo
forme pas vrai en a l'air tellement fier
en plus je
dire
marteau donc là il propose pas
que ilos qu'il l'utilis pour la
défense du coup à l'épo il envis pas
trop qu'il utilis ça pour se battre
entre en
fait récment
ils
dansilâts la mais sur cé d'reésent
philoshe h avec la possibilité qu'il se
tape je trouvais ça tellement pas
réaliste comme image ah
ouais à l'époque ils avaient que ça je
sais pas si tu te rappelles le M6 qui
était passé à l'époque mais c'était que
ça c'est débruitages par-dessus une
image montrée en
boucle vous avez tellement peu à montrer
à
l'époque parce que maintenant on est
quand même inondé avec Internet on est
inondé de paléoart mais à l'époque des
beaux paléoart bien renseignés c'était
super dur à trouver c'était ça que je
trouvais pas réaliste comment il s'est
retrouvé comme ça plter dedans
là ah ou il se balada en troupeau de
troupeau qui en avait rien à
apparemment il y a personne quiard il
peut
[Musique]
crever ça j'étais tellement jaloux quand
il touchait la peau du
tu touch la peau du dinosaure
quoi la première fois que j'ai touché
une peau de dinosaure fossile c'était à
Calgary et c'était en
2018 ou 2019 non 2018 non c'était avant
ou en 2018 imaginer je regardais ça en
1993 je me
disais je suis tellement
jaloux et pu après tu as trouvé ces
petit trucs fossilisé cette petite PAP
avec de la peau c'est pas moi qui l'ai
trouvé c'est une de mes étud
c'est j'étais tellement
joli pe du caillou c'est juste du
caillou et
c'est tu sens plus la résine qu'il ont
mis dessus en fait
que oui
ou ah là il parle de la couleur des
dinosaures l'imagination il disait ça de
l'imagination et de la spéculation
rationnelle ce qu'il disait en en
français j'ai gardé je rpond je réponds
ça aussi c'est c'est vrai c'est vrai ça
marche toujours ça marche toujours de
l'imagination et de la spéculation
rationnelle sauf s'ils ont des plumes
qui sont chinois là on a moyen de savoir
mais sinon là oui on peut trouver et
encore pas tout non c'est pas tous les
fossiles qui non pu ça marche pas avec
tous les pigments de toute façon et en
plus ou il y a pas les P il a juste les
mélanozomes c'est même pas les pigments
eux-mêmes c'est juste les cellules qui
contiennent les pigments
c'est
ça là il commençit à représenter les
dinosaures avec la que relevée par
contre ils ont ça a mis longtemps avant
de mettre les les musées à jour parce
que évidemment c'est pas facile de
redresser un squelette qui pèse on est
d'accord que modèle de TX de tout à
l'heure l' relevé non c'est pas tu vois
qu'il a des anim il a une sale
tête
tuzmoi chaque seconde de ma vie est une
souffr
voilà he la fameuse chasse en
meut on a retrouvé trois fossiles
ensemble autour
d'un autour d'un d'un herbivore ça veut
dire qu'il chassait en
meut bon ils sont pas trop mal hein ces
animatroniques mais c'est vrai derrière
entends untit peu les bruits de limite
tu entends les bruit de moteur non par
contre tu vois ils ont les mains en
Jurassic Park oui ou c'est vrai alors
que tout à l'heure alors que depuis tout
à l'heure il nous montre des modèles en
3D où les mains sont vers
l'intérieur alors que là ils sont en
mode Jurassic Park donc tu vois vraiment
le le truc qui a été créé spécifiquement
après le film tu
sais c'est
gianolicus c'est pas des denonicus c'est
desianolicus
[Musique]
youurus thisurus looks different from
the one we saw remember my boy about
color imagination and inform speculation
j'en connais un qui va passer un sale qu
d'heure pas une
belle tantô dur tantôt
cruel c'est marrant ce côté où ils ont
imaginé qu'ils avaient des attaques
coordonné en fait
alors que c'est pas parce que tu
retrouves plusieurs animaux en train de
manger une seule proie queils ont
forcément chassé en tripau ben non
regarde les vautours les vautours les
crocodiles les crocodiles ils attendent
tous au niveau de la même mare parce que
les B c'est là où les herbents vont
passer de toute façon parce a qu'un seul
trou d'eau donc faut bien qu'il vienne
BO donc c'est pas parce qu'ils sont tous
là en train de chasser la même bestiole
que que leur attaque est coordonné quoi
on est reparti sur les TO qui pique les
yeux ah les fameux de cerveaux et donc
en 1993 il disent déjà c'est
Eré juste un gros
pourlere la conver de les grosse
citéut lesiseau
seréqu équilibrage PES organes
sensoriels pas des
senseurs voir un jour sils en parlent de
ça pour l'instant j'ai pas vu passer ce
genre de truc mais
peut-êtreavoir dans le bassin un un
petit organ qui permet de de bien
s'équilibrer il y a beaucoup d'oiseaux
qui
sont après ils se baladent sur de pattes
aussi ils ont pas exactement le même
sens de l'équipe que nous il faut bien
qu' qu'il s'équilibre d'une certaine
manière je sais pas peut-être et puis
pour le vol ça doit certainement être
utile
aussi de la trompette du
[Musique]
parasolocus mettre une image là du mec
de l're conférence
créationniste ah c'est trop c'est quoi
ça c'est
troposurus selon certain trop ha d ah il
regarde pensivement vers le haut oh le
penseur trop d ouais c'est ça c'est
c'est Jid dans dans
Scub je suis un aigle je suis un aigle
je vais devenir un
[Musique]
aigle avec des grands yeux et un cerveau
qui n'est absolument pas comparable en
taille à celui d'un oiseau donc faut
arrêter avec cette
idée non c'est juste non cerau d'oiseau
en plus ils sont tous assez
différents un test de
me un accent britiche que est très très
briticheas ah oui avec avec les Bab
d'enfant je ne comprends
[Musique]
pas fait passer ça pour des cris de bébé
dinosaur c'est ça
[Musique]
on arrête de rigoler bêtement à
côté
[Applaudissements]
non
pas des fou pas des
éventails j'ai pas des ventilateurs
quoi des
ventilateur la traduction la traduction
YouTube est un
[Musique]
peu comm les tortu
quoi mais là on a trouvé les adultes les
juvénil
associ il me semble que les U je sais
plus est-ce que les ufs de mayasora ils
sont piétinés DUP parce que sils sont
piétinés ça veut dire qu'ils
étaient ça c'était super commun comme
image d'avoir les les cératopsiens qui
forment un cercle autour des juvéniles
ça se voyait partout mais c'est par N
part c'est juste parce qu'on pensait que
il défendit
avec histoire avec les
éléphants un en mettant le PE
derrière je pense qu'ils ont juste
comparé ça à des
éléphants je rappelle dans6 une scène il
y avait un tricératops qui se servait de
sa colerette et qui se metta dans une
grotte cette pour boucher l'entrée de la
grotte pas deette mais ça
marche
[Musique]
carnaval trad
c'estp
ça ét REM en question ça je crois
récment peut-être que les étai pas dans
la cage thorque mais c'est juste avait
une
accumulation que je
regarde tout ce qui été dit à l'époque a
plus ou moins été remis en question
manièreut les trucs vraimentiments bien
qui se mange entre c'est possible
aussi comm
[Musique]
des ça fait longtemp déjà à l'épo qu'
fais parce que
c'est que tu vois facilement sur
les ou
déjà que déjà ger en fin 1800 l'avait
fait sur des ufs je crois qu'il l'avait
déjà fait aussi sur des bah oui
totalement fait sur je rappelle d'un
article de de la de de l'époque
ouè ils ont systématiser ça
c'estand pendant sa dans les années 70
je cro qui avait systématisé
ça
[Musique]
SP je pense ce truc m'a formaté beaucoup
plus que que je l'imagine parce qu'il
arrête pas de répéter rappelle-toi la
taille du cerveau ça ne compte
pas ce truc m'a beaucoup plus formaté la
taille qui compte on vous l' dit du
cerveau mais c'est vrai
il le succès évolutif des dinosaures pe
avir avec la taille de leur cerau j'ai
beaucoup d'ESP comm pour nous pour nous
on s'imagine que ça coule de sources
mais en réalité le succès évolutif de
manière
générale n pas relatif à la taille du
cerau ça dépend dans quoi vous passez
dans quoi vous vous mettez vos en fait
pour vous c'est l'intelligence qui vous
permett de vous développer par rapport
au autres espèces si la T du cerveau est
importante maintenant c'est pas ça si
vous avez d'autres avantages la taille
du cerveau n'est pas forcément
important tu dem une tortue la tortue
non avir une
carapace car bien r dire avoir des
grandes
d ah ça y est l'extinction des
dinosaures les dinosaures étai déjà sur
le déclin avant la
disparition pe
mammifè c'est le pend
sud-africainens que les petits
mammifères av mangé tous les UF des
[Musique]
dinosaures autre théorie que
l'augmentation de la lumière du soleil a
transform a rendu tous les dinosaures
aveugles et Bron j'ai glissé
[Musique]
chef ah
mant bon bà on est dans les années 90 ça
fait déjà un moment que on est au
courant des trappes du décan et l'impact
de
météoriteor
dire c'est marrant parce que tu es là on
est en 1993 et on te montre c'est la
météorite et et les
volcans et puis peut-être un long déclin
avant et on est toujours là en fait ça a
pas trop changé en fait on a pas
d'autres preuve on en est toujours à ce
débat là long déclin ou extinction
rapide les volcans ou les météorites là
j'en parlais encore dans le tout dernier
palé new je ve dire est toujours le
temps de la science mesdames et
messieurs ça prend du temps d'élaborer
des consensus beaucoup beaucoup
c'est que des pitivers
là la lave ça rend glissant apparemment
Gliss voilà l'avantage du fond vert
c'est que que tu vois tout à l'heure tu
avais un tyrannosaure sur fond de
cascade maintenant tu as un tyrannosaure
sur fond
d'extinction encore musique
é
liv élabore l'hypothèse qu'en fait c'est
les les frères Alvarez avec le scénario
de l'hiver nucléaire qu'ils ont
développé pour le pour leur hypothèse de
l'extinction des dinosaures ah ou donc
c'est la météorite hein la météorite
déclenchant un hiver nucléaire qui
aurait en quelque sorte conduit à la
détente dans les années 80 parce que du
coup les gens ont commencé à se rendre
compte de ce qu' de ce que le le genre
de je suis déconcentré là
je psychédélique c'est ça
pyque le truc
c'est ouais donc c'est avec c'est avec
justement ce scénario de l'extinction
des dinosaures par la météorite qui
ressemblerait à un hiver nucléaire que
du coup la détente ce serait un peu
accéléré parce que il sera rendu compte
à quel point ça pouit êre
destructeur c'est St qui ça je sais pas
jusqu'à quel point c'est vrai mais je
trouve ça
intéressant c'est une hypothèse comme
une
autre
[Musique]
c'est pas étonnant c'est on appris à
voler ça c'est du Flam c'est du
Flamingo c'est pas n'importe quel
flamant d'ailleurs c'est du Flaman c'est
du Flam on voit ils sont petits non ceux
c'est pas des
FLAM ça c'est du canard ou de l'OIR de
je ne sais
quoi je suis un aiggle je su c'est une
buse ça c'est une
buse
alors reparti sur le début
parce que cette animation était
tellement bien qu'on va la remettre
hein je suis raid je suis très
raide c'est marrant il y a juste les
papates qui bougent le reste du corps ça
bouge pas tu as l'impression que la
papat elle fait juste t t t t t
t on a du mal à croire que 10 ans après
ça ce sera euh sur la terre des
dinosaures
hein même même pays euh même même
production hein
c'est pas produit par la BBC mais même
pays quand
même tu viens de le dire il y a 2
secondes techniquement c'est
quiation
Richard Richard se met à faire des clin
d'œil un petit P tacozor c'est un petit
un petit
tacozor le Muséum d'Histoire Naturelle
Natur hisory
mum Paul Barret il était déjà là la
vache Paul Barret c'est le c'est le
gérant des collections des dinosaures
justement au Muséum d'histoire naturelle
de Londres peut-être que justement c'est
lui qui a pu aider pour ouais mais je
pensais pas qu'il était déjà là en 93 il
a quel âge Paul Barret 50 ans c'était
peut-être son tout début il était
peut-être étudiant à l'époque ouais
ouais il était peutêtre étudiant parce
que ouais 50 ans je veux dire là c'était
1993 c'était il y a 30 ans maintenant ou
il y avait 20 ans a il était en il était
en
Masters
commencer ouais c'est bien ouis la
vache bon
alors alors alors bah 20 sur 20 pour
moi j'ai pas mis les petites
pancartes qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce
que
vous je sais pas Paul Taylor tu crois
que c'est le même que Paul
Taylor Paul attend Boro associat ouais
bon attend B il était depu longtemps
c'est sûr il est toujours il est dans
tous les bons coups hm hm bah je sais
pas on met sur 20 bah oui moi je dis 20
sur 20 de toute façon je suis
complètement
objectif la nostalgie bonsoir non il y a
pas du tout de nostalgie là bah écoute
j'aime beaucoup les musiques les
musiques sont géniales j'aimerais bien
avoir ça dans les documentaires actuels
franchement ce serait cool et même dans
les films d'ailleurs ce serait vachement
cool aussi parce que franchement ils
sont tous sur le même modèle en ce
moment
euh l'explication était sympa bon sur
Richard Owen je pense qu'ils ont un peu
mal calculé le personnage mais on va
dire que il était sympa et sur pas
Wikipédia à l'époque non mais mais c'est
bien c'est bien expliqué aux enfants en
fait c'est pas mal je trouve que c'est
c'est bien
fait par contre
ouais non la 3D faut oublieré
mais tu te rends compes tu te rends
compes que ah ou mais non ah non mais
non mais mais là mais
waouh 10 ans après ça c'est sur la terre
des dinosaures c'est fou c'est fou oui
enfin c'était aussi la même année c'est
jurassique c'est voilà c'est ça mais
justement mais là non parce que du coup
déjà cette année là s'il y a Jurassic
Park qui est sorti et enfin tu sais ce
que à quoi ça va ressembler la 3D
normalement dans ces CASL oui bon ou
surtout quand l'argument de vente c'est
fait avec les mêmes ordinateurs que Ch
par alors les ordinateurs oui le staff
non mais ça c'est pareil ça ça a eu plus
d'influence sur moi que je peux imaginer
parce que mon désamour pour les pour les
docufiction je pense il vient de là
aussi c'est-à-dire que moi j'ai comme
j'ai j'ai grandi avec ça qui est pas du
tout un docu fiction du coup bah on te
montre le fossile et exactement ce qu'on
en déduit dans la foulée h et tout est
expliqué tout es tout es documenté du
coup ah c'est très très bien expliqué je
trouve que du coup ça m'a complètement
formaté le cerveau quoi je me rends
compte à quel point en fait ça m'a
complètement formaté à attendre du
documentaire une explication sur
pourquoi on me dit la chose qu'on me dit
Oui puis te montrer le fossile pas juste
montrer de construction 3D qui au final
ne sert pas à grandchose juste à te
faire des belles images parce que là bon
niveau construction 3D les belles images
il les avait pas trop donc fallait bien
qui tape sur autre chose quand même
voilà attendss là c'est important ce que
tu viens de dire ton hypothèse de
travail à toi c'est c'est pas ce qu'on
sait faire de la belle 3D maintenant
qu'on ne montre plus les les fossiles h
c'est c'est complètement une à mon avis
c'est valide parce que dans beaucoup de
choses maintenant tu te rends compte que
bah on préfère te montrer des beselles
images et Racon pour une belle histoire
par-dessus plutôt que de montrer trois
bouts de fossil qui au final nont pas
grand-chose à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
spécialiste dire parce que bah là tu
reviens sur du basique mais montrer une
dent pointue en disant c'est comme ça
qu'on sait qu'il est carnivore oui mais
maintenant on préfère te montrer un
super truc en 3D avec une bouche énorme
machin tu sais parce que j'en ai moi des
gens sur le la chaîne qui me demande
dans les commentaires comment on sait
qu'il est
carnivore que not alors que ça me paraît
tellement moi ça me paraît tellement
obvious je m'attends pas à ce qu'on me
pose la question je bah bien sûr enfin
je veux dire regarder ses
dents mais c'est vrai que si tu as
personne pour te l'expliquer au final tu
peux pas le savoir non je pense je je
pense honnêtement que maintenant on est
parti parce qu'on peut faire des images
qui bah qui t'enmett plein la vue au
final mais qui te raconte pas grandchose
à part une jolie histoire après c'est
pas vrai de tous les documentaires il y
a des documentaires qui mais c'est pas
les documentaires qui ont le plus de
succès non plus ce qui montrent les
fossiles oui c'est pour ça que on
préfère les jolies images ben c'est
comme pour les fil quand tu as de la
jolie 3D tu dis ah c'est sympa ils ont
bien fait le taf quoi alors que des
trucs en effet même si l'histoire est
pas
ouf et puis après il y a ceux qui
complèp après il y a ceux qui on la
moche 3D là ça se voit tout de suite le
flash
salut bon alors sur 20 sur 20 allez sur
franchement j'ime moi j'aime bien la la
Muso et j'aime bien la la transmission
du savoir donc allez je vais lui donner
un petit
17 tu as vu ça tu as vu ça
documentaire 1993 17/ 20 allez mais
franchement mais c'était bien mais après
vraiment les points Richard en bon
l'utiliser pour expliquer aux enfants
alors tu aurais pris quelqu'un d'autre
qui a effectivement fait de la bulga je
dis pas Richard Owen
pe pas trop dans le personnage ou B
c'est le fondateur du Musée Richard Owen
oui mais c'est pas lui que j'aurais pris
genre tu mettons jeux prendre Richard
Owen tu tables sur Richard Owen mais en
fait tu le prends dans le background
mais tu prends genre son aide qui est là
qui va effectivement essayer d'expliquer
la science tu vois et qui lui est plus
intéressé à transmettre le savoir parce
que Richard lui est just intéressé
àécrire les trucs dans Rick Morty c'est
clairement Rick voilà et du coup tu vas
être avec arrête de dire n'orte quoi
et toi tu vas partir avec avec Morty
parce que bah lui au final il est un peu
plus un peu plus abordable tu vois
refaire ce documentaire mais en mode
Rick et
morti non la caractérisation personnage
fait c'est un professeur par espèce de
petit
con
non oh non ferme les yeux et tire sur
mon doigtti
puis le coup du super
Saian
tu tu fais tête constipée et hop ça te
téléporte puis bon je sais que la 3D
c'était un argument de rente à l'époque
ça all est toujours d'ailleurs est
toujours mais mais non là c'était
vraiment moche pas top non ok je préfère
tu vois les passages où ils nous ont
montré des figurines sur un fond vert où
là il tourne
autour là c'était c'était déjà un peu
mieux par contre la 3D moche là non
petit galimimus le petit galimimus il
est où il est là il est là il est
là là je préfère encore ce passage là où
là finalement ça oui tu vois c'est joli
ça c'est joli mais alors la 3D c'est pas
cher aussi c'est pas cher aussi mais tu
vois ça c'est c'est mieux par contre non
le reste les passag c'était c'est cringe
mais tu vois c'est cringe dans le dans
le sens limite ça me flanque les jetons
parce que ça me fait penser à ce vieux
jeu vidéo où tu étais capable de passer
à travers les textures des fois et tu
tombais dans un trou sans fond et ça ça
me flanquait les chetons quand j'étais
GAM le charme du rétro ah mais c'était
c'était une horreur pour moi j'avais
toujours peur à chaque fois que je
faisais un je veux pas tomber dans les
textures j'avais quand il y a certains
jeux ça m'était arrivé comme ça c'était
sur l'ordi j'étais j'étais petite des
premiers jours en 3D où tu passes à
travers des textures et tu tombe tout
d'un coup dans un vide et ça me ça me
terrifiait et ça ça me fait un peu
penser à
ça
exactement non tu tu atteints le fond à
un moment mais du coup tu tu passes
soudainement dans un truc tout noir et
tu es là tu fais mon Dieu qu'est-ce
qu'il y a sur l'écran
oui j'étais facilement impressionnable
petite mais mais mais bon c'était non
c'était maentis alors revoir ça c'est
mes cauchemar qui reprennent vie
[Rires]
ok bon ben en tout cas on vous mettra le
lien en description et puis euh bah du
coup merci beaucoup Sophie et ben merci
de mavoir fait découvrir ce monument de
la culture dinosaurri trop bien
faitesnous savoir en commentaire si vous
le connaissiez celui-là parce que à ma
connaissance je suis le seul tu es le
seul ouais comment ça tu es le seul il y
a jamais personne y a personne qui l'a
vu ce truc tu veux dire que c'est passé
à la télé on faire non c'est jamais
passé à la télé ce truc donc faites-le
moi savoir si vous le connaissiez avant
sinon allez le voir il est bien ah oui
tu avais acheté la belle ch et ou
d'accord bon et ben bonne soirée
amusez-vous bien
salut